chamber has finally been nerfed
well
kinda riot removed one of his trademarks
upped the cost of it by 50 credits and
increased its overall audio the problem
is this isn't really the nerf that
chamber needed and it might have even
made things worse
right now
he still seems broken
[Music]
alright guys i have a confession to make
aside from being addicted to valorant
and buying skins pretty much every
chance i get
i'm also a filthy chamber man i spent my
entire week off insta-locking him in 90
of my ranked games and we're almost back
up to diamond which is dope but
unfortunately the day that i've been
dreading for months is finally here it's
no secret that chamber has become a
problem for everyone whether you like
him or not he's just way too strong
of course people are going to run into
cryo cells and let them ace i don't know
well look at yay he's doing the same
chamber was released back in november of
last year in patch 3.10 and almost
immediately he became an alternative to
jet because of his ability to hold the
operator on paper it sounds fine right
we were all waiting for an agent to
break jet's dominance on the op but the
problem is riot didn't design chamber to
be a duelist-like jet
he's supposed to be a sentinel this
matters because every team on every map
tries to run at least one sentinel to
hold down sights with their utility and
gather info now chamber can do these
things but he also has the same
characteristics as a duelist he can play
aggressive angles and take fights just
like you'd expect from a jet player just
look at some of the stuff yay was
pulling off in iceland
oh as i say that
yeah
that's definitely just sentinel behavior
chambers headhunter is basically a
pocket guardian while his alt is like a
cs go op on steroids but with an even
higher rate of fire on top of that his
rendezvous ability allows him to take
aggressive peaks get a pick and get to
safety without any risk chamber is a
killing machine and again this would be
working as intended if the guy was a
duelist but he's not so clearly
something needed to be done and back on
april 29th jeff landa tweeted out that
riot would be testing out some changes
to chambers trademarks on the ballerin
pve the changes would remove one
trademark raise the cost of it by 50
credits and also increase the overall
audio volume of the ability and since
then everyone including myself has been
left wondering why riot decided to nerf
the one aspect of his kit that actually
makes him a sentinel to put it simply
riot saw a problem but they only really
fixed half of it but the craziest part
and something that i expected them to
nerf is the cooldown on his tp whether
it's used destroyed or recalled there's
only a 20 second cooldown on rendezvous
which is absolutely insane to me this
allows him to get a pick teleport out
and by the time he returns to the action
there's a pretty good chance that it's
back off cooldown but before i get too
worked up i have a confession to make
i've been abusing chamber for months now
and i didn't want to miss out on the fun
just like you guys
they were both dropped
hit 20. that helps
makes you feel better
30 seconds left
so do i think his trademarks needed to
be nerfed yeah they're definitely
busted they last long as hell and the
radius of the slow feel that they create
is pretty big but i think riot's main
priority should have been nurse to his
rendezvous or his alt they're what
allows him to play like a duelist but
instead riot went ahead and nerfed the
one thing that actually makes him a
sentinel
you had one job riot
one job naturally most people felt that
riot had completely missed the mark with
these nerfs i think it's a little silly
that they removed
the only defining thing about a sentinel
from him from his kit the chamber nerf
that's proposed there's a leak about it
is so weird that they're taking away an
alarm bot like if i was to make a change
to chamber that would be like the
literal last thing i do why wouldn't
they change the slow or nerf the deagle
or nerf the op or change the radius on
this anything but they took away an
alarm bot or changed the tp now riot did
at least give us some insight as to why
they went ahead with these nerfs even
after they received so much backlash
from the community valerant com
strategist jeff landa said quote
chamber's trademark outperforms other
sentinel tools in both reliability and
power which feels inappropriate given
the amount of defensive combat tools he
has spread across the rest of his kit we
believe chamber's identity is defined by
his unique weapons and defensive combat
mobility so we are decreasing his level
of global flank protection information
and increasing counter play on a single
premium trap end quote what this
basically means is that riot thinks that
by shooting someone with an op and
keeping away you're doing some sort of
sentinel type [ __ ] i don't know and
seeing as this whole thing brought up
the debate of what a sentinel actually
is jeff cleared up a few things there
too he said quote we believe that
sentinels and sentinel players should
have many options and methods to control
and defend whether it's through the use
of sage's reactive slow abilities
cipher's flank watching gadgets or
defensively oriented combat and guns
like chamber end quote i want to focus
on that last part
defensively oriented combat and guns
i'm not going to sugarcoat this guys his
alt is broken as it's far too easy to
chain kills together with it because the
rate of fire is so high and the slow
field that it leaves upon each kill
seems way too strong
absolute catastrophe as yay finds
perfect timing
annihilates the entire team now i was
never an opera before chamber came out
i'm not someone who came from
counter-strike and i figured it was best
to learn the ropes of tack fps with a
rifle in my hands but chambers just way
too easy to use even someone like myself
who has little experience opting is able
to dominate plaid and diamond lobbies
with his alt and even the normal
operator because of the safety given
from his rendezvous and even if you're a
body shot berry you can do some serious
damage with headhunter on eco rounds i
got flashed
from tower side
one enemy remaining
yeah headhunter is busted but this isn't
just a problem if you're a scrub like me
no chamber has become the most dominant
due list in pro-valorem 2. chamber
dominated the qualifiers for na stage 2
over the past couple weeks with the
highest overall pick rate at 72 percent
my favorite valorem analyst ominous even
helped paint the picture for us a little
more with a graph that compares the
effectiveness of chamber zolt versus
jethav and after looking at 200 pro
matches here's what he found on average
chamber result gets more overall kills
per round more opening kills per round
more multi kills and even contributes to
more round wins on the defensive side if
you ask me
i'm honestly not that surprised but that
last stat is arguably the most important
players like leaf have already expressed
concern over the fact that chamber will
still get the most first duels on
defensive side with the most recent nerf
and after testing out the new chamber i
honestly feel like the nerfs aren't
enough i definitely missed having the
second trademark while on the attacking
side but the problems with his
rendezvous and tour de force still
remain and after speaking at ethos i
know i'm not the only one who feels this
way i still think he's broken um
yeah i mean
again individually still i think he's
the strongest agent you know like he'd
be my go-to to go win ranked you know if
i wanted to if i really want if i really
care about ranking up i would lock that
agent every single game we're gonna see
less jets
probably more chambers um and you know
more other sentinels and more other just
kind of comps that
might just not run um
a duelist at all we won't see how these
changes will affect pro play for a few
weeks now and it's tough to see if the
nerf will cause teams to run a different
sentinel but regardless
as much as i hate to admit it
chambers still broken
alright chambers finally been nerfed
well kinda
i don't wanna smile when i say it though
i've been trying to remind myself lately
to smile
more while i'm on camera
but i'm kind of sad that he's been
nerfed so
i don't know